this program is brought to you by Emory
University
one thing that is coming up through the
office of university and community
partnerships is that office is
developing a matching database site so
if we know that there is a community
partner that has a project that needs to
be done or if their faculty members or
graduate students that are working on
projects we want to get all of them in
the database so for example if you have
a project you can look in the database
and find out who else is working on it
for example we know that diabetes is a
big issue and so we know that working on
food issues is important delivery
systems people having the money to be
able to get the better food to know how
to cook it and so there would be a whole
variety of areas within the university
as well as within partner universities
such as Morehouse Spelman Clark Atlanta
because we want to make sure that we are
partnering in the areas where we can all
work together and not duplicate other
projects if I had my dream I would have
faculty members from all of the Health
Sciences telling me what their areas of
interest are so that I could help the
office of university community
partnerships get that Dave matching
database together and we would have
community-based organizations that would
like our partnership and we would have
funders coming in and saying this urban
health initiative will make a true
difference for people in the
neighborhoods and so we want to advocate
for them and participate and help fund
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University